all right ken have you seen detroit
threat management center no
but you're in for a wild ride baby
i feel like i really am this guy's got
the stone cold stairways got a gun right
in his chest
i mean it's better let's just watch it
it's beautiful sure
detroit urban survival training i'm
going to share with you right now what
to do
if a striker fired weapon is pinning
against your chest against the wall and
a criminal is holding you at bay and the
reason why they're doing this is because
this is how they search you for weapons
how they're going to take things from
you also how they're going to harm you
physically keep you from running or
pulling out a weapon is by getting close
and pinning you to a wall to a car in
this case it's striker fire so there's
no hammer in the back so the first thing
i'm going to do since we can't move out
of the way we can't move offline and if
i were to try to move this as soon as he
saw my hand move he's going to fire
right you're dead don't even try it this
video is 123 million views
[Music]
that means people will try this for sure
look i can see why it's got so many
views look at those gloves look at that
yeah
yeah this guy got serious he's got the
fashion down man all right let's check
how he does that make this weapons not
fire and give an example to human
reaction time when he sees me move he's
going to fire
the slide didn't slide is because i
inhibited it by pushing it to the rear
from neck do you see that guns are
useless kid wait it was so fast you
couldn't even see it
[Music]
are you you cannot tell me that was not
the coolest thing you've ever seen again
so
i'm not sure i'm not trying to poke
holes in this or anything
yes yes but go ahead and try
i got a lot of things to say about this
but the first thing is did he just hit
it with some it's a melger solid cqc
like you know
big boss just freaking takes your gun
apart and gives it back to you like in
the game
[Music]
yeah yeah you're right
i don't know how many opportunities you
get to like fake out your shooter so
they shoot and then they're not
expecting to grab like that but probably
not very often another thing i want to
know
is did he did he grab it after the
trigger was pulled and the slide was
already back because if that's right
he's already been shot he needs to grab
the top of the gun
we'll never know i mean you're just
gonna you're just gonna have to try it
yourself and then you'll then you'll
know okay
okay that was fast though we did this
video where like how to survive these
are different situations i can't believe
i we didn't do this one first it's so
good it's beautiful
watch this then how he disarms the gun
is because i inhibited it by pushing it
to the rear from that from there what we
do is push the barrel back towards the
aggressor and now you have the weapon he
just sliced out of his hand was he
dipped his hand in grease
how do you how do you so easily just now
you have the weapon and if you don't
want to shoot
then you just pin them down to the
ground using their finger and taking
them under control using their finger
sorry i need a little bit more
information in there cheap
okay
no no wait we have a ton of these to
watch we don't have to over analyze it
okay
what kind of lift wrist assailant do we
have here yes that's what i was saying
you got my fingers stuck in the trigger
and now you're pointing at me
i guess i guess i'll die now but ken
there's a there's an explanation to this
if i can find it which is this yeah here
we go much stronger than me he's not he
is not going to let go unless he asks
him correct right we're going to come
here grab our fist
comes right out the hand is not meant to
hold things very well yeah that ken
you wanna hear that again i'm gonna come
here grab our fist
comes right out
the hand is not meant to hold things
very well there you go that's your
answer
that's why it fell off it's the hand
the hand that's been evolved
literally with the function
oh it's not meant to hold things
i can't i can't hold anything
i'm drunk
i feel like you deliver anything by
walking towards the camera with that
smile and pointing you will you'll have
to accept it as true well i'm just glad
he found the fingers to his gloves
that's that's what really matters oh
with the yeah
because the hands aren't meant to hold
very well he needs that texture from the
gloves yeah on the fingers to be i mean
to be fair the way the guy was holding
his hand if you were trying to push down
then yeah he couldn't get away from him
but he pulled it up ah
through the thing
i'm picking up the science these yeah
these are some good tips
yeah
all right let's keep watching i mean
what have we got man in the car if the
gun is to the rear of your head
pin here to the column drive away it'll
peel out
it's not going to work every time
obviously my favorite part about this
whole thing is that it all depends on if
the guy with a gun has watched too many
movies and gets like right in your face
with this long-range
weapon like yeah i can touch you with it
what are you gonna do now use your hands
it's like john wick what a great movie
but man those guys just ran straight at
him every time to get beat down bro just
shoot if you are victimized by a
carjacking we're going to share with you
some intelligent options victimized if
it's here in the window head forward
you're offline
[Music]
i guess this is like a meme review this
guy's blowing up it's so funny
how hard is it to shoot a guy it can't
be that hard i know cops miss all the
time right but i get it like if you're
undercover you're getting shot at and
you're trying to just shoot back yeah
you're gonna [ __ ] miss but if you're
the one with the gun trying to shoot
somebody it ain't not it's not hard yeah
i think at least as someone who's never
fired a gun
what he's trying to show us there's like
these perfect setups if you have a guy
that just intends to do you harm then
yeah you're screwed but if you got a guy
that doesn't actually intend to shoot
you and it's just trying to scare you to
get what you want then yeah
yeah that's a good [ __ ] elbow
on the gun and peel out
so you endorse these videos ken is that
what you're saying oh this is this is
great this is absolutely
nice fantastic advice
uh he also sells uh some merch i'm gonna
share with you how you can use
this keychain
felix
he did not
what do you what do you mean
what is that he's what is that he's got
what is that is a self-defense device
and that's exactly how you hold it too
a self-defense it
looks like guns in the background good
guys oh yeah
i've seen those in a few places but
they're definitely
[Laughter]
like they they pinned this one my mom
has the same weapon in her nightstand
probably
i don't know i don't know but uh it's
also the way to demonstrate using it
like they make it seem like it's a i
don't know a nuclear bomb or something i
don't know how powerful that is the
bones of the hand very painful
very painful take the point stab
yourself to the arm
very painful very pain also use
very painful right here
very painful what if the person's
walking in your space you can actually
take the front of it go right to the
chest
back them off use the point or
the blunt side
take your hand here
and press it right on the nose
if they grab you what does that do
what is that there that isn't you
bear hug
you can actually take it you don't have
to use the point you can actually use
the side of it go right here at the top
it'll back them up
give your family your friends a hard
time and aggressing on them take your
take your uh key chain go right here to
the shoulder
this device can help protect you and
your family uh-huh
mm-hmm
just like if you subscribe you could win
a million dollars
that's it
the good thing is the best legal
coverage i love it i mean it couldn't it
could you don't know did everything butt
stab the dude
yeah i feel like anyone holding this is
just going to stab them in the eye or
some [ __ ] i don't know it's like let me
use the blunt side to squish your hand i
mean i was i was with it until that one
that one was a little
yeah was a little out there yeah
okay this one is great because he
doesn't do anything i mean well just why
[Music]
wow
how
you just turn around
i feel like someone that has an assault
rifle kind of maybe knows what they're
doing at least i'd like to think that
maybe i don't know if i this reminds me
what is it called have you ever seen the
clip it's like a a martial arts master
and it doesn't actually do anything but
like move his arms a little bit and like
all the guys coming after just like fall
on the ground it's like a demonstration
piece of chi
[Music]
what is this
they're making fun of the guys but then
it shows it
[Applause]
his chakra is so strong
damn
that is awesome
oh
yes
[Music]
oh we gotta watch more of these but
another time let's check this guy out
how did he fall over from that you just
push their face man you know
they're big brained individuals they
lose their balance
[Laughter]
so much density up there any any
movement we'll make a fall over come on
amazing they also have this one uh
to demonstrate with a female and it's
just uh okay
what was that i feel like maybe don't
teach the women to do that
i grew up running by the forehead and he
falls over like a toddler
i've seen my kids do the same move to
each other you know one pushes one other
side of the head and he goes
she's just going to lift her hand into
the orbits she's going to pull the bones
into the orbitals
there's pain in here that she's going to
pull up and cause there's no
the pain is causing his head to go up
lock up you're better off just trying to
poke him in the ants right
that poor guy he's self-conscious about
his hairline and she's touching on it
and he's like
i have a few strands of hair left there
stop asking my baby hairs yeah
speaking of kids defense they do have
some
yeah got him
detroit irwin's rival training
that's so cute he's like smirking he's
like that's adorable anyway detroit
threat
oh there's one even his watch has it oh
my god
oh yeah yeah that's branding on point
dude they should start a fashion line i
i love it uh he does like to talk about
his uh watches there's another video
here i found i don't know i just thought
it was funny he doesn't say anything
survival training we're gonna answer a
question we received from the internet
it's about our watches in this case my
superwatch and now i don't use that
square one i had before that's a great
watch it's a 4g watch it is an
underwater watch that has uh sound video
and it's actually a telephone it's a
great one broke the band so now we broke
the band use this great watch and this
is a great watch this is a casio range
man this is actually a solar powered
watch and if you get this it gives you
navigation lots of uh tools this is a
great watch so if you're looking for a
great watch this is one right here oh oh
cool
what is it what about is that is it
hashtag ad what is it no i think he just
wanted to he bought a new watch and he
wanted to show everyone with him
so cute it's kind of sweet i don't know
why
it is i mean just don't tell them that
most of those apps work through your
phone and that
today
not cool yeah yeah my bad my bad i love
this mustache too yeah he's a beautiful
man he looks like an adult child anyway
i gotta give him props because you know
clearly a lot of people clown on this
dude i think for probably good reasons i
think it's good to maybe that
acknowledge that you know maybe don't
necessarily try this if it was more for
entertainment i would be more on board
you know but he does embrace the meme
and it's kind of funny actually
no no no no no no no
what is he doing in heaven
imagine dying and getting shane from the
self defense guy here's parallel
universe twin or something
no i like if you really think about the
story the guy got shot went to heaven
and then that same god the gun went to
the detroit man he got shot also trying
to say move and here he is
but he messed up
yeah just show me how to do it they must
have killed them no no no that will get
you killed what you just did we'll get
you killed i'm just visiting i'm not
actually here with him i'm just i'm just
helping oh they addressed that
the story
[Music]
they skipped their training and that's
what happens that'll get you killed
always come to trade here
how much does the training cost i got to
know yeah it's probably too much do you
remember the guy that like
like the chef dude that like did a
little salt sprinkle thing on his elbow
yeah yeah yeah did he open a restaurant
was charging ridiculous yeah crazy
amount of money yes this is just so they
can take a photo with him
yeah yeah oh my god that's pretty smart
i don't know for sure but i read
something like the possibility that he
wouldn't even like pay in the employees
that well like he's like making all this
money off of his meme and he's like
yeah i mean
i'll come out make an appearance give
him some little elbow elbow salt you
know hey look it's the guy from the meme
and here we are you can take a shower
now he monetized selfies he's pretty
smart actually i get it ah
exciting it's on top of the curb you
gonna start doing that no i actually had
an idea of the opposite you know how i
don't do photos oh you pay them to go
away
no yeah i give them you know because
people want something out of experience
but i don't want to take a selfie with
them so my idea was to give them this
business card to show that they met me
and on the back of it there's an nft
they get rich from meeting me you're
welcome
you become like oh like
a pokemon everybody's got to come
down and get it yeah no no
but there's a password you need to know
the password anyway that's uh i thought
he was going to hand him a business like
a card like no no no i'm not do don't do
selfies and yeah but i think it says he
rod sorry
that's pretty good actually there's two
versions there's one that gives you
money and the other one just says i try
to get a selfie with pewdiepie and fail
yeah
how many are there three different ways
what he did was he blocked using his
forearms here so i couldn't extend which
caused the weapon to come out of my
hands one that's true it does fly out of
your hands like that
yeah
i've played baseball before it happens
you know you you hit the ball and also
you let it go and it goes in the stands
hit three people and their child is part
of it they should have went to training
yeah and you know why because the hand
is not meant to hold things
very well that's detroit threat
management thank you kevin for joining
on this survivor
now this is a treat now we will live our
survival training continues subscribe
and you could survive forever and win
billion
today's birthday birthday
i want to send some love
to today's sponsor nordvpn when i was in
italy i tried to stream but my internet
was so bad it barely functioned so they
graciously sent me a
startling which worked amazingly and
finally i had internet long story short
love nordvpn everyone should use a vpn
let me explain to you why if you're
browsing on someone else's wi-fi or
network which i know you do all the time
you need to use a vpn to protect
yourself and your data your isp can see
everything that you're doing everything
they can see everything unless you use
nordvpn of course nordvpn has a strict
no logs policy you don't have to worry
about any of that it's super easy to use
on your phone or your computer bada bing
bada boom you're in one click it's super
fast
i personally been loving using nordvpn
recently because i've been showing might
say these old swedish tv shows that
obviously you have to be in sweden to
watch
nor vpn one click and i'm in
i'm in sweden watching mysterio verholm
and if you sign up using the link in
description make sure you use the link
there's no code lordvpn.com pewdiepie
and that way you get a huge discount on
a two-year plan plus one additional free
month
you're welcome they also have a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you're not
sure about a vpn or how it works or what
the purpose is you can try it out for
free for 30 days and get your money back
100 guarantee uh they've just been a
great sponsor and i'm very happy with
them so it's a great service it's a
win-win check it out with the video